hi I'm Chris Wilson from grinding Gear
games build of the week is a weekly
video series that showcases interesting
character builds created by path of
Exile community members someone is are
generally very popular builds we've made
a lot of changes to summoning and
forsaken masters and were eager to see
what builds people would come up with
under the improved system the build
we're showing this week is a good
example of a powerful modern summoner
character this character uses two types
of minions his zombies are supported by
blind multi strike and merely splash the
blind gem makes them substantially more
defensive as they greatly reduce the
threat of monsters they hit he raises
quite a number of these zombies at once
his spectres are supported by increased
duration to spell echo and minion damage
at first glance this may look like a
strange combination but is because his
target monsters undying evangelists
increased duration helps the length of
their proximity shields and spell occur
dramatically increases the power of the
delayed blast skill this build uses a
lot of auras including vitality
disciplined grace purity of fire and
purity of elements vile haste is used
for a short burst of very fast speed for
your minions and supported by increased
duration the hatred and haste auras are
also used but is supported by the
generosity gem this amplifies their
effects applies it only to your minions
various skills are used to assist the
minions further desecrate Convocation
flesh offering mode offering ended
feeble on the passive trade as a focus
on minions energy shield or effect and
buff effects death achievement was
allocated to increase the Specht account
a natural calm provides significant
energy show bonuses and some maximum
lightning resistance the necromantic
aigis key stone has been chosen so that
the player shield protects all of his
minions rather than him the blood magic
Keystone allows him to apply all of his
auras to his life total so that he's
perpetually on low life
mortal conviction reduces the mana
reservation of the auras significantly
increasing the total number of auras
that he can run these auras leave the
character with low resources but this
doesn't really matter because his
minions don't die that often
this helmet adds two additional levels
to minion Jim stocking it into it it's
where he houses is raised Dombey Jim she
breath is a popular summoner amulet that
has been corrupted in this case to
increase minion damage the bones of
hollow boots are good for this build
because they provide reasonable bonus
in addition to increase minion capacity
midnight bargain is used as the
character's wand its drawback of life
reservation is reduced on this boat
because life is not used for
survivability because of the necromantic
acres Keystone passive the properties of
the equipped shield apply to minions two
shields are used depending on the
situation in the samples frame or crest
of horrendous Solaris lorica is used as
a cheap version of Chevron's wrappings
it enables the character to survive
chaos damage that would otherwise be
lethal due to his low life and use of
energy shield these two flasks are used
to heal the player and minions due to
the of animation mod they both benefit
from the player being permanently on low
life due to his auras it's very
interesting to see how similar this
builders to one of the old snapshotting
summoner once thankfully it doesn't have
a 25 minute setup phase we enjoyed
playing this build because a rewards
smart and active play despite most of
the combat being performed while minions
if you're new to path of Exile would
like to play just head on over to path
of exile calm or search for it on Steam
we recently released the forsaken
masters expansion and new leagues with
fresh economies so it's a great time to
get into the game if you'd like to
submit a build for next week's episode
just supposed to build Gaiden in the
class forums on path of Exile calm
thanks for watching and see you next
time